Today's topic is one of the most famous stories in statistics.
It's also about where babies come from. I know you know where babies come from,
but there used to be this tale. That's what I grew up with.
That babies come from stalks.
If that child is asking awkward questions of his or her parents,
parents would say, well, you know,
the stalks bring the baby in draped from their bill
in a blanket. That's where your baby brother or your baby sister came from.
Have you figured out where that came from?
Why stalks were associated with babies at all, or so there's a theory.
It's something to do with, um, storks being a traditional symbol of,
of fertility, a religious symbol of fertility.
And another theory is that stalks, when they go fishing,
they're looking for embryonic life forms in the water. So that is,
that is two theories. Um, I don't know, I'm, I'm an economist, you know,
I'm not, uh, not as sort of a studier of mythology and ritual. Anyway, anyway,
to get back to the important stuff, which is the statistics.
So stalks deliver babies. This is the old story.
Let me try to prove that to you, statistically. Um, I've got my,
I've got my paper here, so,
and this is just going to be a illustrative plotting.
You mentioned two axes and here,
this is babies per year and here we have the number of
stalks.
And if you just take a bunch of European countries and I have actually seen the
data, what you find is Turkey. If I remember, and this is Poland,
and then you might have Germany here and then you've got a whole bunch down
here, a couple of there, and it's not the world's best correlation,
but it's, it's not the world's worst correlation, uh,
loans down here with not many babies, not many stalks.
You got these big outliers here. You've got nothing here.
You've got no places with loads of babies and no stalks.
You've got no places with loads of stalks and no babies,
and you can draw a best fit line. And it goes like that.
And there was actually an academic paper about 20 years ago with the title
stalks deliver babies P equals 0.008.
And without going into the technical details,
you probably know that according to the conventional standards of statistical
significance, that means this relationship is not a coincidence.
There is definitely a correlation between stalks and babies.
Now you're probably thinking to yourself, okay,
so what's the trick because surprise, surprise talks.
Don't actually deliver babies. Email me.
If you actually want me to explain where babies do come from, I get a reply.
Well, maybe, uh, so what's going on here?
What's going on here is basically, as I said, I think this is Turkey.
This is Poland. There's there's Monaco. There's Luxembourg.
There's Lichtenstein down here,
lots and lots of places with very small amounts of land.
There are no stalks and there are no kids basically.
And here are places that are really big, lots of stalks, lots of babies.
And that's what's going on. That's enough to drive that statistical correlation.
So the amount of land is the hidden is the hidden factor.
Yet the secret thing that's driving, both a large population,
which means a lot of babies and is driving the large number of stalks because
bear in mind, I'm not, I didn't say birth rate. I'm sure there's well,
I expect there's no correlation for the birth rate.
What I'm talking about is the number of babies born each year in this,
in these countries, which is very closely correlated to the population.
You would also perhaps expect a correlation with trees.
Yeah, yeah. Probably number of trees versus number of babies a year.
Trees also deliver babies. You could, you go in all kinds of places like this,
and there were lots of these, um, these spurious correlations out there,
she does a website maintained by a guy called Tyler vigilant,
I think called spurious correlations full of all kinds of fun stuff like this.
But I said at the beginning that this is one of the most famous stories in
statistics. There was made famous by a fellow called DRL half.
And here for me is where this gets really interesting.
So dwell half was a journalist. And in 1954,
he published a book with a title, how to lie with statistics.
It got a rave review in the New York times.
It became many people say the best selling book about statistics ever
written.
And I loved it when I was a teenager reading about all of these
tricks, all the different ways you could be deceived.
He's got the storks and babies in there.
It's got loads and those are great examples. It's got dodgy maps,
it's got dodgy graphs. It's got all sorts of great,
great examples. It's very funny book. I'm not the only person who liked it.
And Goldacre who wrote bad science and many other great books about numbers.
He praised through our half Charles Wheelan who wrote a book called naked
statistics. He said it was an homage to Darryl half.
There were loads of fans of drought, half out there.
This book is in praise of statistics. This,
this book is supposed to be doing a service to statistics program.
So that I think is where the important question lies.
It is loved by nerds,
but it is not really in praise of statistics because what do El half is doing is
in chapter after chapter example, after example,
he's debunking dodgy statistics,
and he just doesn't have a lot of positive examples of statistics being
used to aluminate the world.
And that's where I start to get a little bit queasy because that book was
published in 1954. And you know what else happened in 1954,
two great statisticians epidemiologists, Richard doll,
and Austin Bradford Hill provided some of the first solid evidence that smoking
cigarettes might well give you lung cancer because it's the same year,
two different visions of what you can do with statistics there L half is saying,
it's a bit of a joke. It's a bit of fun.
I'll tell you the story about the stalks and the babies, but don't,
don't ever take statistics too seriously,
because they're just a way for people to lie to you.
Austin Bradford Hill and Richard doll are using this vital
to find out the answer to one of the key medical questions of the
20th century. And when you think about it,
they couldn't have done that in any other way than using a statistical lens.
So even to notice that lung cancer cases were on the increase and they were
massively, you need to be systematically counting cases of lung cancer.
I mean, you maybe there'd be some anecdotes, but you need the numbers.
You need the data.
And then to show compellingly that there's evidence
of causation. You really need to work hard with the statistics.
There's a lot of people at the time thought it was something to do with cars,
which is not crazy.
We think about it between the beginning of the 20th century and the 1950s lung
cancer is on the increase. So our cars, loads of cars,
maybe it's something in the tarmac. Maybe it's something, you know,
coming out of the exhaust is not a crazy idea,
but it turns out it wasn't the cars. It was the.
Cigarettes. This is, this is so important.
This is such a key fact understanding that this thing is true.
This is saved.
Literally tens of millions of lives, possibly hundreds of millions of lives.
And you've got to L half in, remember this,
the best selling book ever published about statistics saying
don't ever take statistics too seriously because they're basically
liars. We'll use them to lie to you.
There's a twist in this story because in the 1960s,
the U S Senate held hearings to decide whether a
cigarette packets should have warning labels on them, should smokers be warned.
You know, maybe this is going to kill you.
And they got all these expert witnesses in to discuss the evidence.
And one expert witness came in and he told the senators, look,
don't worry too much because there are a lot of funny correlations out there.
Let me tell you about stalks and babies.
And he sat there and he told the senators all about how you could demonstrate
this correlation between babies and stalks.
He used a slightly different example, but the same basic argument.
And it's the same with,
with cigarettes and lung cancer and the Senator who was chairing the commission
said,
do you seriously mean to tell me that there is as,
as casual a relationship between smoking and lung cancer as the risk between
stalks and babies and the, the expert witness says, yeah,
they seem to me to be about the same and his name.
You may have seen it coming derail,
half the guy who published how to lie with statistics,
he was actually working on a sequel course,
which was never published called how to lie with smoking statistics.
So he'd taken this, you know, this, you know, funny,
witty skepticism about statistics and this great little book,
and he'd soured it into this nasty cynicism that everything out
there is fake news.
You can't believe a single thing you're told and had then gone to work for the
tobacco who found him to be the perfect witness for their case.
If you'd like more great stories like this from Tim Halford, check out his book,
how to make the world add up.
This is what it looks like just in case you need to know the links in the
description include a chance to get yourself a signed copy.
You can also catch Tim talking with Matt over at standup maths. Again,
links in all the usual places.